entré dans un monde enchanté les
lumières sauvages de Toir sont installer
un parcours d'un peu plus d'un kilmètre
à travers les jardins du château pour
voyager au cœur des grands continents
des peuples et de leur écosystème c'est
effetérique c'est vraiment magique
onetombe complètement en enfance on voit
tous ces animaux c'est c'est vraiment
magnifique moi j'ai bien aimé ça a l'air
bien la la nouvelle partie d'Asie qu'il
ont fait donc on on va aller découvrir
ça je trouve ça magnifique il y a eu des
améliorations enfin des des changements
par rapport aux années précédentes ils
ont ajouté des scènes de vie avec des
personnages ça fait 2 3 ans qu'on vient
avec ma famille et enfin c'est de c'est
toujours aussi beau jusqu'au 10 mars
2024 le zoo safari a choisi d'illuminer
les fins de journée avec une 6e édition
de ses lumières sauvages le thème de
cette année l'Asie un an de travail de
réflexion pour les équipes qui proposent
une nouveauté un renouveau avec encore
beaucoup beaucoup plus d'immersion avec
le labyrinthe qui est complètement qui
sera complètement illuminé cette année
et puis derrière vous vous avez l'Asie
qui prend vie avec tous les animaux
d'Asie et juste derrière moi les
bouddhas aussi les temples qui vont
pouvoir animer cette scène le parcours
est agrémenté de près de 3000 lanternes
75 % d'entre elles sont restaurées
chaque année un souhait du site il ne
vous reste plus qu'à vous laisser
[Musique]
porter